why did star wars kill off or denigrate
to almost all of their major female
characters prior to rey why is jar jar
binks well jar jar binks keep watching
to learn the truth
there are some real world situations
that blockbuster franchises shouldn't
even try to approach the phantom menace
is a great example of this phenomenon as
the movie decided that what star wars
really needed wasn't just a new
spaceship and a cool new lightsaber
instead as part of anakin skywalker's
backstory slavery was introduced as a
foreground element to the star wars
mythos in a movie containing fart gags
and big space battles the true horrors
of slavery just can't be appropriately
represented and ends up serving as a
distraction for all future escapades in
basically all star wars films that
followed and was slavery established as
not just existing but being common a lot
of the lore and the prequel trilogy
feels like small potatoes who cares
about the planet kamino being erased
from the jedi archives when people are
still being enslaved across the galaxy
right from the start of this collection
of films a prequel trilogy went way too
far in establishing slavery in a
franchise that just isn't capable of
exploring this concept in an appropriate
fashion
before the prequel trilogy the aliens in
star wars weren't exactly devoid of
racially stereotypical behavior but it
wasn't a prominent feature that all
changed within minutes of the phantom
menace first the los angeles times
observed that newt gunray speaks in an
accent that charitably speaking sounds
like a caricature of an eastern accent
it's all downhill from there as a trip
to naboo finds jar jar binks sounding
like with the baltimore sun like into an
unfortunate combination of minstrel and
rastafarian stereotypes slate notes that
leaving naboo doesn't help matters as
viewers soon meet a potentially
anti-semitic stereotype in watto who
flies around talking about his love for
money and another offensive accent
classic aliens in the star wars
franchise made you want to buy their
action figures the aliens and the
phantom menace largely reminded
moviegoers of ugly racial stereotypes
from earth but without any commentary to
justify their presence
after luke skywalker is rescued from the
clutches of hoth's cold weather at the
start of empire strikes back he's
talking to han solo and leia organa when
the discussion turns into an argument
between organa and solo concerning the
possibility of leia harboring secret
romantic attractions to the scoundrel to
prove that solo is wrong organa proceeds
to plant a big smooch on luke's lips
well i guess you don't know everything
about women yet
[Music]
in the grand scheme of star wars lore
it's apparent why this scene goes too
far given that skywalker and organa are
eventually revealed to be twins
separated at birth in defense of the
empire strikes back that piece of lore
wasn't defined yet when the film was in
production with george lucas initially
planning at one point to have luke's
sister be a new character still as part
of a sprawling saga the greater context
of the duo's relationship makes this
moment squirm inducing rather than its
initial intent of registering is just
humorous no wonder this kiss has been
burned into the minds of star wars fans
for all the wrong reasons
that was so wrong
throughout her screen time in solo a
star wars story l-337 is all about
giving droids autonomy and freeing them
from their human masters this passion
comes to a head on a kessel mine mission
where she leads a droid revolution just
before getting shot and killed in the
heat of the battle here it appears that
l3's storyline has come to an end but
solo isn't finished with this character
just yet shortly afterward el3's
consciousness is uploaded to the
millennium falcon a development l3 has
no say in and that all her previous
actions suggest she would be vehemently
against it's a conclusion to her
storyline that's meant to make the
audience happy seeing how lando's robot
pal is now inside lando's ship however
it only serves to give l3 a send-off
that undermines her sole notable
character trait it also apparently
exists mainly as fan service to explain
a line by c-3po and the empire strikes
back
i don't know where your ship learned to
communicate but it has the most peculiar
dialect
the screenwriting in solo is often
muddled but the treatment of l3 here
takes things to a whole new level
in attack of the clones anakin
skywalker's descent to the dark side of
the force begins when he sneaks into a
tuscan raider camp and finds his mother
dying from extreme injuries after they
share one final goodbye she passes away
anakin then bursts out of the tent she
was held in and slices down a tuscan
raider the screen cuts the black but
skywalker later informs padme amidala
that in an act of rage and revenge he
killed all the tuscan raiders on the
premises i slaughtered them like animals
the trajectory of the prequels trilogy
means that anakin skywalker has to grow
more and more nefarious as these movies
move along it was only inevitable that
one of these features would contain a
sequence where skywalker commits some
unspeakable act of violence however as
executed here skywalker's vicious
revenge goes a bit too far mostly
because there's never a moment for
attack of the clones to properly process
the gravity of this event it just moves
on to the next thing
though it makes sense in his character
arc the slaughtering of the tuscan
raiders is clumsily executed enough to
undercut its important intent at least
when anakin later kills the jedi
children in revenge of the sith it's
treated like the horrible event it is
once leia organa is captured by the
nefarious crime lord jabba the hutt in
return of the jedi the space slug
proceeds to dress the princess up in a
chain bikini which leia wears for the
rest of the first act it isn't until the
action ships off the planet to tatooine
that she gets a new costume though leia
didn't don this bikini again in return
of the jedi this costume quickly became
an iconic piece of imagery that was
common in cosplay circles and
merchandising the latter use of the
chain bikini costume is downright
disturbing given how organa is kept on a
chain and forced to wear the skimpy
outfit by jabba the hutt however
lucasfilm merchandising had no problem
taking this image and putting it on
posters t-shirts and other items the
exploitation of leia and by extension
actress carrie fisher only ended when
disney bought the rights to star wars
and announced they were discontinuing
merchandise with a bikini outfit
a little more than halfway into the 2008
movie star wars the clone wars audiences
meet a new character in zero the hut
he's a crime lord like the much more
famous job of the hutt but there are a
few key differences between the two for
one thing zero speaks perfect english
for another he's got the voice of truman
capote and is covered in purple skin the
combination of a flamboyant voice and
the color purple which is often
associated with the lgbtqia plus
community makes it clear that zero the
huts is a gay stereotype of the sort
that belongs in hollywood's past not
present there's nothing inherently wrong
with having a villain character who's
incidentally gay but it is strange to
lean on such broad queer stereotypes as
a way of defining your antagonist this
becomes even more recognizable and
franchised as devoid of nuanced queer
representation of star wars it also
doesn't help that zero's character
traits stemming from queer stereotypes
feel like they exist to make
heterosexual viewers giggle out of
mockery while he may be one of the brand
new characters introduced in the star
wars the clone wars feature zero is also
an unfortunate relic of when
flamboyantly evil queer villains were
common in children's entertainment
padme amidala is nowhere to be seen in
the original trilogy of star wars movies
from the 1970s and 1980s thus it's only
a matter of time before the lone
prominent female character in the
prequel trilogy is either killed off or
otherwise pushed to the sidelines even
with everyone aware of this
inevitability however it was still
shocking how revenge of the sith chose
to dispose of the then pregnant amidala
a short time after amidala is force
choked by her husband anakin skywalker a
medical droid notes that they can save
the babies but amidala herself is dying
for who knows inexplicable reasons
perishing shortly after she informs
obi-wan kenobi that anakin still has
good in him amidala's primary purpose of
birthing luke and leia is complete it's
a strange whimper of a conclusion for
the character especially since it
contradicts how leia states in return of
the jedi that she can remember her
mother that pre-established lore could
have allowed an easy out to avoid
killing off amidala instead revenge of
the sith goes too far and killing off
the only notable woman in the origin
films and gets rid of her in a bizarre
fashion the boot
in solo a star wars story history was
made with the introduction of val the
most prominent black woman to exist in
live-action star wars media up to that
point introduced as a clever rogue
married to tobias beckett the character
doesn't last long in solo during a heist
gone arrive al is one of two close
allies to becket that ends up perishing
sacrificing herself to ensure that the
mission could be finished properly val
dies the first major set piece in solo a
star wars story isn't even finished yet
and a promising character is already out
the door given that this development
exists solely to motivate beckett's
subsequent actions the demise of vow
can't help but feel like a classic
example of fridging bridging as
explained by vox is a narrative device
that sees a female character die to
motivate the story's male protagonist
this tiresome narrative staple feels
especially out of place in a star wars
movie given how often this franchise has
been all about subverting expectations
rather than giving in to them the lack
of many other black women in star wars
also makes this death extra
disappointing even actress tandy way
newton who played val commented on this
in an interview about solo now could
have been a landmark star wars character
but instead she was a disappointing
example of how little noticed black
women get in this franchise
everybody loves grogu aka baby yoda fans
make memes about him t-shirts featuring
his adorable mug are everywhere he's
even gotten his own macy's thanksgiving
day parade float however that doesn't
mean grosgu is devoid of controversy in
the star wars franchise one season two
episode of the mandalorian features
grosgrou scarfing down the eggs of their
frog-like alien passenger while the
titular lead of the mandalorian tells
groggu to knock it off this baby is
always eyeballing the canister
containing the eggs that is a dark gag
fans did not respond well to grogu's egg
consumption which in effect reduces the
population of this already struggling
alien species to even lower numbers he's
eating their children a brief backlash
occurred that proved so loud that a
creative arts manager at lucasfilm had
to put out a response defending grogu's
actions by comparing the frog eggs to
chicken eggs of course the controversy
didn't last long and people were soon
back to making adorable gifts however
this character's controversial approach
to satisfying his hunger shows that any
star wars character even fan favorites
can end up going too far check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about star wars
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]